your doctor may recommend you get a
carotid endarterectomy if your carotid
arteries are narrowed or blocked with
plaque in your neck are two major blood
vessels called the carotid arteries
which carry oxygen-rich blood from your
heart to your brain you can feel the
pulse of the carotid artery in the side
of your neck
fatty deposits called atherosclerosis
can build up inside the carotid artery
these plaques can narrow the passageway
of the artery and interfere with blood
flow to the brain this blockage or
narrowing is called a stenosis if blood
flow to the brain is blocked temporarily
a transient ischemic attack also known
as a t IA may occur when the blood flow
is completely obstructed as in a carotid
artery blockage a stroke can occur
before your procedure an intravenous
line will be started a carotid
endarterectomy is usually done under
general anesthesia which will put you to
sleep for the duration of the procedure
in this case a breathing tube will be
inserted through your mouth and into
your windpipe to help you breathe during
the operation sometimes a carotid
endarterectomy is done with local
anesthesia if local anesthesia is used
you will remain awake but your neck will
be numbed you will probably also receive
some sedation on the side of your neck
along the blocked artery the surgeon
will make an incision that may run from
just behind the ear to a point above the
collarbone
[Music]
your surgeon will find the carotid
artery and temporarily clamp off blood
flow through it
your surgeon will open up the artery
and may place a shunt or temporary
bypass to keep blood flowing to the
brain
your surgeon will then remove the plaque
within the arterial walls
after the blockage has been removed he
or she will sew the artery back together
usually placing a patch to widen the
artery slightly the patch may be made of
part of one of your veins or an
artificial material such as Dacron
[Music]
finally your surgeon will close the
incision with sutures or staples and
cover it with bandages a temporary drain
is frequently left in the wound
[Music]
after your operation you will be taken
to a recovery area where the staff will
monitor your vital signs and neurologic
condition you will be given pain
medication as needed and will gradually
progress from a liquid to a solid diet